okay
hi everyone uh welcome to another
episode of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
i think it must be a sign of the recent
earth day that there are questions here
about
climate change and so on um
if there's a way to create climate
change that must mean there's a way to
reverse it
we comment on that well let's see okay
let's talk about global climate
and those kinds of things
so it's a complicated subject because
it's a mixture
of science public policy
ideology politics lots of other kinds of
things
um i can talk mostly about the science
side of it
the the question is
first first thing to say is the climate
of the earth has changed over the course
of the time that the earth has been
around it's changed pretty dramatically
um the the oceans have gone up they've
gone down
the uh the average air temperature has
gone up it's gone down the carbon
dioxide concentration the atmosphere has
gone up it's gone down uh
things were very different at different
times in history
and if you look at charts of many kinds
of parameters
about the atmosphere they sort of bounce
around kind of randomly
there are few like uh
that that it looks like we humans have
actually had an effect on
um but there are many others that we
haven't had an effect on or at least not
one that is easy to detect
and i think perhaps worth understanding
is
well is it the question of so what if
you have an effect
on some parameter of the earth's
atmosphere what what
consequence will that have and that's
where things get quite complicated
uh and it gets complicated to see what
uh what so let me tell you a little bit
of the history as far as i know it
um when i was very young
i think uh i was one of my earlier
science memories from when i was like
two or three years old
i lived in england there was an
extremely cold winter 1962-1963
and the word was there's going to be
another ice age
so that was the um uh and you know ice
ages are something that happened in the
history
of the earth every so often and it's not
a regular kind of thing although there's
some evidence of some
kind of regularity in that pattern the
earth gets very cold and um
uh the the kind of the the area of the
earth that's frozen
right now the arctic expands to be
a larger part of the earth and um
and then the ice age is over and um all
the glaciers melt
and withdrawal and so on much of the
topography
of you know the the hills and valleys
and so on in lots of places
is a consequence of where glaciers were
in the last ice age so i'm trying to
remember how long it's been maybe
10 000 years 20 000 years since the last
ice age
um and uh maybe i'm wrong
a little bit by that maybe it's as long
as 50 000 years i'm not sure um
but a lot of features of terrain
um were um
uh were formed by those glaciers in the
last ice age and so they're all kinds of
funky things like
there's an island off the coast of
massachusetts called nantucket that has
this funny horseshoe shape
and you wonder how on earth was an
island made in that shape
and the answer is it was there was a
glacier that was pushing down through
other parts of massachusetts
and it pushed a bunch of mud and gunk
ahead of the glacier
and it's called in geology it's called
the terminal moraine
is what gets left over when the glacier
has pushed that far
and this is the stuff that got pushed
ahead of the glacier and it leaves this
kind of horseshoe shaped island
and so there are lots of features of of
uh current topography that come from the
last ice age
and there are different um uh there are
parts of
the world where there was uh things were
now islands were not islands and so on
and so on and so on things have changed
things will go on changing that's the
nature of geology and so on and the
nature of planetary science
that there is progressive change in the
climate of
planets like the earth now
what are the consequences of those
changes well
uh the for example
in i think it was around 1650 there's a
thing called the mondo minimum which was
happened to be correlated with the
disappearance of sunspots on the sun and
it's not clear how significant that was
but in any case it was really cold like
in europe
and for example in various rivers in
europe
they never melted during the year they
were frozen the whole year
and this happened for i don't know 50
years or something
and then um and then things started to
warm up again
and and so these variations in in
average temperature that happen
in sufficiently short time scales that
it's within recorded history
these are not kind of geological it's
not like the dinosaurs have it one way
and we have it another way
it's in 1650 it was something different
and now
it's changed and so these progressive
variations of
of things like temperature but back to
the story of um
at least my experience with these kinds
of things so 1962-3
people said there's another ice age
coming terrible you know everything's
going to get very cold
okay so well that didn't
really pan out um and the reasons for
expecting that were
a bit unconvincing in the end i'm not
sure that i know all the reasons that
were given at the time
but um uh it didn't pan out it had to do
with things about the earth so but it
had to do with some other kinds of
other kinds of things about the sun and
so on didn't turn out to be be correct
okay the next important thing that
happened
from my knowledge of this history is a
quite different
episode which was the episode of the
ozone hole
so in the earth's atmosphere
there's there's light that comes from
the sun
most of the light from the sun makes it
to the earth's surface
but in addition to visible light coming
from the sun there's also ultraviolet
light
that is higher frequency uh
electromagnetic radiation higher
frequency photons come from the sun
and that ultraviolet light uh
would be pretty bad for us i mean it's
the ultraviolet light
is the main thing that causes us to get
um uh
uh to you know get sunburned and things
like this
um that's the uh it's also also bad for
our
eyes and so on um ultraviolet light is
not very good for us
a certain amount of it gets through the
earth's atmosphere but a large part of
the ultraviolet light from the sun is
blocked by this ozone layer
in the upper atmosphere of the earth
which conveniently is there
um so that means that we biological
organisms didn't have to evolve
to sort of fend off the ultraviolet
radiation
it was blocked for us by the earth's
atmosphere so
ozone just to explain what that is so
the earth's atmosphere is about 78
nitrogen 20 oxygen
most of that oxygen is in the form of o2
that means a molecule in which there are
two oxygen atoms
bound together but there's a sort of
slightly less stable form of oxygen
which is o3
three oxygen atoms bound together in a
molecule that's ozone
ozone is a good absorber of ultraviolet
radiation
and ordinary oxygen ordinary oxygen
molecules
can be turned into ozone by the effects
of ultraviolet light
in the upper atmosphere and so in the
upper atmosphere there's a whole bunch
over
and that ozone blocks the ultraviolet
radiation and means that we don't get
sunburned
and it's all a good thing okay so
then there are some things called cfcs
uh fluorocarbons i guess there are
molecules
uh there are molecules that involve
fluorine and carbon and hydrogen and so
on
and those particular uh substances
the gases were used as propellants and
aerosol cans so when you have one of
these aerosol cans and you
you know press the button and it squirts
something out at high speed
that was you know whether it's whipped
cream or something else
the cfcs were used as the uh
as the as the gas that was used to sort
of
push things out quickly in an aerosol
okay
well turns out cfcs interact badly with
ozone
and they basically destroy ozone and so
everybody was up you know uh sort of as
a
as just well we're making our you know
whatever it is with our
our aerosols our aerosol cans and that
they're powered by
the you know the things that pushed out
with cfcs and the result of that
is lots of cfcs in the earth's
atmosphere
and that interacted badly with ozone and
started destroying the ozone in the
upper atmosphere of the earth
and in particular there was this uh
apparent hole in the ozone layer
that developed initially over the
antarctic and um
people were very worried that oh it's
going to destroy all the ozone in the
atmosphere
and we're all going to get sunburned and
it's bad news
okay so then the various you know
governments got together
and uh sort of banned cfcs so can't use
them for aerosols
um and aerosols started to be done a
different way
okay the good news was that fixed the
ozone hole problem
so in other words people learnt that
that was kind of a good experience of
well we goofed slightly nobody figured
out that cfc's
used for aerosol cans would produce this
bad effect on the ozone layer
turned out it happened we rolled back
using cfcs
the ozone layer went back to normal we
don't get sunburned any more than we
would normally
it's all good okay so that was that was
sort of that episode
well then another thing that happened
was
during the cold war the time when the
soviet union and the u.s were kind of in
this
in this standoff uh starting in the well
1950s 1960s 1970s most of the 1980s
um the so the big threat was
uh you know the thousands of nuclear
missiles that both countries had
would something happen and they'd all
you know they get released and there'd
be some giant nuclear war
one of the things that was thought to be
a disaster from that nuclear war
was this thing called nuclear winter and
so the concept was
you release a bunch you you detonate a
bunch of nuclear weapons
um and you end up throwing dust up into
the upper atmosphere
and that dust would block the sun and
would cold
cool the the um the surface of the earth
and you'd have kind of this
this artificial winter now you know
perhaps something to be worried about
because
probably it happened to the dinosaurs
probably when the
asteroid hit the earth 65 million years
ago
one of the things that it did was to
throw dust up into the upper atmosphere
the block the sun for a year or two and
if you're a reptile cold-blooded reptile
and
and things get really cold it's sort of
bad news and that might have been
one of the things that was was really
bad news for the that caused the
extinction of dinosaurs
um in the 1800s there was a volcano
called kakatoa
in indonesia that was a a giant volcanic
explosion
and it too put a bunch of dust into the
upper atmosphere of the earth and it
cooled the earth a bit
um for a certain for for a year or two
so there's sort of evidence that that
could have happened so this was kind of
a
a one of the really really bad things
about having nuclear war there are lots
of bad things about having nuclear war
but one of the really bad things is
it would lead to this nuclear winter and
it would make the earth cold for
for some number of years etc etc etc and
there was evidence
um from planetary exploration on mars
for example there was evidence of dust
storms
that might have had you know global
effects for some period of time and so
on that was was
sort of used as a as a piece of that
story um
a popular eyes of science carl sagan
also scientist carl sagan
um was very uh involved in the whole
nuclear winter story
which became sort of a mixture of a
science
story and a politics story um of of one
of the that's one good reason not to
have a nuclear war i think there are
others as well
but um okay so then
we come to more modern times and um
uh people were trying to figure out
the climate of the earth what would be
the evolution of climate on the earth
people
uh people have been trying to do weather
forecasting
back in the 1950s
was okay so how did weather forecasting
get done originally
so what do you need to forecast the
weather
the there's a pattern of of of air flow
around the earth there are regions of
there are high pressure areas
where the pressure of the earth's
atmosphere is higher they're low
pressure areas
there are fronts between the high
pressure areas and low pressure areas
um there are places where there's cloud
cover there's places where there's moist
air and so on
there's different humidities all these
kinds of things so back
up in the 1930s 40s and so on
there was some
and earlier there were efforts to do
weather forecasting by just
making measurements and weather stations
around the world
and just sort of knowing oh if we have a
a high pressure area it will push itself
out in this direction
and the front will move in this
direction and the wind is going this way
and so this thing will move and it's
something that was done by human
meteorologists human weather forecasting
people
actually the the thing that really
launched that
was the availability of weather stations
whether
uh getting weather data around the world
and the chapter was a chat called uh
fitzroy who actually was the captain of
the original
beagle uh ship that took charles darwin
around the world as a naturalist where
he collected all these specimens that
led him to formulate this idea of
natural selection and so on
anyway um admiral fitzroy was among his
other achievements
later in his life after the voyage of
the beagle and so on
um he started the for the british
admiralty the british navy
he started this big network of weather
measurements around the world
um to try to start doing weather
forecasting
um and uh so sort of the the raw
material for weather forecasting was uh
was initially in is today um weather
stations and today there are around 30
000 professional weather stations
around the world and lots more not so
professional weather stations
um that feed data into a big um uh big
network
uh the the sort of aggregated by the
world meteorological organization
but um uh and aggregated in in the us
by noaa and so on and so on and so on
and the national weather service and
and such like but okay so so for a long
time the way weather forecasting was
done was these rules of thumb about
oh there's a high pressure area here and
it moves this way
and under as a result of winds and etc
okay in 1950 uh actually particularly as
a result of uh
a mathematician named john von neumann
um
had this idea we're going to be able to
use computers these new computer things
they're going to make it easy to do
weather forecasting
we don't have to have humans doing
weather forecasting anymore we'll just
automate it with computers
okay turned out to be easier said than
done because it turns out that the
mathematical equations
of fluid flow are very difficult
equations to solve even for a computer
and they're difficult both in their
structure and they're difficult because
they depend
sensitively on the particular values of
temperatures in one particular place
can have a big effect in some situations
on on the predicted weather some number
of
days in the future but through the 1960s
that progressively developed
more computerized uh weather prediction
and there are these centers for weather
prediction there's one in boulder
colorado
in the u.s there's one in redding in the
uk i think
uh for part of europe although i don't
know what's happened now that
the uk has exited with brexit i don't
know what's happened to the
european weather prediction operation um
probably
well i don't know what's happened to it
but um in any case there are what these
are
are big computer codes being run taking
as input
data from the weather stations around
the world so weather stations
will measure every 15 minutes or
sometimes every five minutes
they'll measure temperature wind speed
wind direction humidity
um and and so on uh very often well
basically every airport has a weather
station associate weather
measurement thing associated with it
because it's used to provide weather
information for planes that are coming
into that airport
but there are in addition other weather
stations um that exist in different
places that all feed their data into
these
these various networks and um
so that's the input the weather stations
give the input
then these big computer codes that run
and there's sort of been a big effort
spent to uh figure out to be able to
do more weather prediction and so the
shorter the time you're trying to
predict for the easier it is to predict
um and so if you're predicting for a day
it's fairly straightforward if you're
predicting for three days it's quite
more difficult
five days if more difficult by the time
you're out at
the stage of months and things it gets
to be really really difficult
and and you get to be wrong a lot of the
time it's also the case that there are
different parts of the world where it's
easier and more
difficult to predict the weather so
there are places in land
um where essentially there'll be some
pattern of of
air and clouds and so on it's just being
blown by the wind
without much change across this this
area of flat plain
um and so that's quite easy to do the
prediction um in other places like when
i was growing up in england england is
an island with
you know ocean around it and all kinds
of the gulf stream current
coming from the gulf of mexico and so on
and just a lot of complicated stuff
weather forecasting is pretty hard for
for the uk
um and so it uh the weather forecast
didn't tend to be terribly accurate
but over time computerized weather
forecasts uh have gotten more accurate
it's still very difficult to do uh
weather forecasting
um and uh things like clouds are really
difficult to deal with
uh the effect of clouds and the details
of the structure of clouds and so on
and they're they're still i don't know
how many layers of the atmosphere
are now accounted for but it may be tens
of layers at most
which doesn't really account for all the
details because for example you know the
surface you know the the wind
uh at the surface of the earth but the
wind can be way different
you know you can easily have at the
altitude the planes fly at
you could easily have 100 mile an hour
200 mile an hour winds
uh which you you don't normally have
anything like that at the surface
because at the surface there's sort of
friction from the the air blowing across
the the solid ground that that slows the
air down that doesn't happen as you get
higher up
um but there are many details of that
that are hard to know
so in any case uh there is this effort
weather forecasting weather prediction
it's gotten progressively better there
are kind of modern innovations that one
can
try and use with machine learning and so
on we've done
all kinds of experiments using machine
learning to do various kinds of weather
forecasting
uh you can do a certain amount by
looking at uh weather radar
where you're seeing whether radar is um
is something where you can see
uh rain and so on from uh because the
because the raindrops reflect back the
radio waves that are part of the radar
um
and so you can detect where the rain is
um and
uh by using that you can you can get
some more information for weather
forecasting but
so short-term weather forecasting few
days something we've kind of learned how
to do we've got computer programs that
do it it's been a big
big struggle but it's sort of more or
less there okay now the question is
what's going to happen
to the global climate of the earth a
year from now two years from now
five years from now um that's really
hard to figure out
and it's hard both in the mathematical
computation that has to be done
and in the question of the are the
models correct clouds have been a
very big deal and those kinds of models
they're still dealing with only just a
few layers i don't know maybe five
layers or something
of the earth's atmosphere and it's
really difficult to do those
computations
and um so
that's you know when people say what's
going to happen to the earth's climate
what's going to happen
if this all that happens well you have
to run this model and these models are
really hard
and it's really hard to know if you're
getting the right answer
and sometimes people say well let's run
a bunch of different models
and see so they all give the same answer
well sometimes that's a good idea
sometimes it isn't i'll tell you
something about weather forecasting so
sometimes it'll say
you know x percent chance of rain some
some forecast will say there's a 30
chance of rain what does that mean
because
you know you've you've got a weather
model that
uh given the temperatures and weather
and wind speeds and all that kind of
thing of the
measured the weather stations you just
compute
what the predicted outcome based on this
weather model
will be it just gives you a definite
result
okay so what's actually happening is
because you haven't measured
every temperature and every wind speed
everywhere
you you there's pieces you don't know
and so what people do
is they say let's run the model many
times
let's run the model first we know what
it is at the 30 000 weather station
positions
but we don't know what the values of the
temperature and wind speed and so on are
at other places
so let's fill those in kind of at random
and let's do that let's say a dozen
different times we'll fill in difference
of random values in other places
and let's do these calculations for a
dozen different
possible uh initial conditions for a
dozen different possible
uh sort of choices of the current
temperatures on the earth and so on
and let's see what results we get and so
the answer will be
some of those with some of those
assumptions about information you didn't
know right now
it will rain in wherever
and with some of those assumptions it
won't rain and so when people say
there's a 30
chance of rain roughly what that tends
to mean is 30 percent of the models
that will run say there's going to be
rain and 70 say there isn't going to be
rain
now i mean it's a tricky business
because sometimes
there's there's a question of of of you
know
you can't run it for all possible things
you don't know about
and there's a question of how clustered
are the results and sometimes there are
different kinds of weightings and
sometimes
even with a single the the main weather
models that get run in the us are run by
the national weather service
well actually i think they're run by
nowhere and distributed by the national
weather service
um but uh uh you can end up with
different um weather outlets
telling you different things about what
the probability of rain is and sometimes
that comes because they looked at this
these collection of different forecasts
from different runnings of model
and they had different ways to weight
those different
uh different pieces of the forecast and
so they end up with a different
percentage
okay so anyway that's that's the story
for
um for kind of weather forecasting
but again then the question is what
happens when we try and project far into
the future we try and work out
you know 50 years from now what's what's
going to happen to the
the climate on the earth it's just
really really really hard
and the uh there are some large-scale
phenomena that are known like the el
nino
phenomenon which is a sort of ocean
current air
thing which is a kind of a a season-long
kind of phenomenon
and there are other things at a slightly
larger scale
i mean when you have a hurricane it
comes through
but it's all it all happens in a week or
two it's all done
there's some slightly longer term
structures that develop in this earth's
atmosphere
um that allow you to understand things
then there are pieces
then they're things that have longer
sort of time horizons like
the melting of glaciers the uh you know
the the
the sea ice disappearing and reappearing
and so on those have slightly longer
longer cycles okay so then
the question is the next question is so
okay
next thing to ask is so it's very hard
to do these predictions
so the next question is what's actually
happening um
and uh uh the um
um what's actually happening on the
earth
and as i say you know in the history of
the earth
the climate has changed things have
happened but let's see what's been
happening
more recently well first thing to ask is
uh what data can we get from the past i
believe the the longest
time series of of temperature
measurements on the earth i think it's
the central england
temperature series which i think goes
back to the 1600s somebody's been
measuring
different person presumably has been
measuring the um
uh temperature um
in somewhere in england for that period
of time
uh most of the time series of
temperature measurements go back
to the uh about about a century or so
some of them a little bit less than that
and until you have all these all these
data points of and they were
there were a lot of different
measurements made a lot of things that
make it really difficult
to understand things from those 30 000
time series of data there's about five
terabytes of data
that exists in the standard collection
of data about
uh uh weather um
climate in in the history of the earth
from ordinary weather observations
and um so one thing i i mean i remember
looking at this years ago
is like what can you see about the
trends in for example the average
temperature of the earth
earth from those measurements well it's
really difficult because those
measurements have been made
at you know very populated places there
are very few measurements in some parts
of the
of the world that the places that have
lots of airports
lots of fancy buildings and so on have
many
much higher concentration of temperature
measurements than other places and then
the other problem is
uh used to be the case in the us for
example that there were often
temperature measurements made at post
offices
um and those post offices for a while
were out in the middle of nowhere and
out in the countryside but eventually
the towns grew up
and uh you know you end up with a post
office in the middle of a town
and one feature is a spoon as soon as
you have things like asphalt on the
ground
that's sort of black-ish it absorbs
sunlight
it gets warmer than something which is
just a field of grass or something
so things if you are looking over time
scales of decades
the things can change just because
the temperature measuring device is in a
different environment than it was in the
past
so it's pretty difficult to take that
data on its own and figure out much at
all
um and you know for a while people were
saying oh
you know there's evidence the earth is
warming sometimes they said it was
cooling but usually they said it was
warming
based on that data i was never able to
pull out any reasonable signal from that
data alone
there's other kinds of data there's data
from ice cores
of drilling down in the antarctic or
something
and seeing the different uh the
different amounts of pollen and other
kinds of things that you get
in different levels in the ice as a
reflection of the the average
temperature of the earth there are also
tree rings
where when when there's a uh you know
trees grow
every year they they um because they
grow differently in different seasons of
the year if you
if you look at the the slice through the
tree you'll see that there's
thicker um there's there's darker areas
and lighter areas
that um uh go year by year and if it was
a
a better year for the tree the tree
might have grown a lot more that year
and so the tree rung will be
way thicker and so there's some data
from tree rains and so on about climate
going back for the time that trees have
been
the the particular trees that you can uh
uh that are around today
have have been around so maybe most
hundreds of years maybe a thousand years
something like that
so there's some data from these kinds of
things a bit controversial some of that
data
um there's also the the one thing that's
actually easier to measure is carbon
dioxide levels in the atmosphere
and that although its effect is less
obvious
but the amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
is determined by well how much you put
there
and what puts carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere when
we we breathe in oxygen and we breathe
out carbon dioxide
plants work the opposite way they
they they um they pull in carbon dioxide
and they produce oxygen
um burning things typically pulls in
oxygen
and releases carbon dioxide so when we
are off burning things like we have you
know internal combustion engines in cars
and they're burning gasoline or we have
coal
fuel plants and they're burning coal or
we have airplanes and they're burning
uh airplane fuel these kinds of things
those kinds of processes of burning
things produce carbon dioxide
and and bring in oxygen so it's been
possible to measure with satellites
uh well it's possible to measure quite
directly the the carbon dioxide levels
um in the earth's atmosphere and yes
they have been going up
so regardless of what happens with the
you know temperature which is a little
bit harder to figure out
there's some data from satellites on
sort of average temperatures
which also i think shows a systematic
increase and that's not based on just
individual measurements at weather
stations and so on
but the basic answer is well yes uh
there has been over the course of the
last hundred years or something
an increase in carbon dioxide levels
maybe an increase in average temperature
um etc and that's presumably
that is presumably caused by us humans
now meanwhile
there's just variations going on in
average temperatures and sea levels and
things like that
that happen just as a result of change
of climate that happened for reasons
that we don't understand very well
to do with the the way the sun is
working the way the earth's orbit works
the way the atmosphere works et cetera
et cetera et cetera there are
complicated cycles not very well
understood
but yes we have some effect um
you know there's seven billion of us and
it's sort of not totally surprising
that we have some effect on the earth in
a sense it's
it's um it's impressive that we can have
an effect we might have thought
you know that all the things we do the
earth is just going to keep going and
nothing much is going to happen but we
have some effect
so another question is what are the
consequences of that um
uh of that effect so so the next
question is what happens if you have a
lot of carbon dioxide in the earth's
atmosphere
uh power energies just commented here on
on um
um uh on on one point here the um
uh the uh yeah venus
is a bad case analysis for what happens
if you just have
i think it has a lot of carbon dioxide
it has some other gases as well in its
atmosphere
but basically you can end up with a
situation where because there's sort of
a lot of
cover of cloud on venus or a lot of
carbon dioxide in the earth's atmosphere
you can end up with uh this so-called
greenhouse effect
how does a greenhouse work a greenhouse
has glass
the the light from the sun comes in
through the um
uh through the glass because the glass
is transparent
but then uh and that that light
heats up things in the greenhouse but
the heat
which is associated with infrared light
the heat glass is not transparent to
infrared light
so the heat gets trapped inside so the
the light
comes in the energy from that light
heats things up inside
but the heat can't escape through the
through the glass because the glass is
not transparent to infrared light
and so the idea is the same thing
happens in an atmosphere with carbon
dioxide
that light from the sun can come in and
then it can't escape and so the
temperature of the
the surface of the earth goes up now
there are many many many things that can
affect that for example one thing that
affects it
is what is the average albedo of the
earth
so the albedo of something is if if you
shine a light on a thing
how much of the light that you shine on
it comes gets reflected from the thing
and how much is absorbed
so if you have something like i think
the moon which looks to us
pretty pretty you know bright is
actually reflecting only
you know some few percent of the light
that falls on it's actually it's
actually made of quite dark rock
but you know the light of the sun is
bright enough that it looks to us like a
kind of a
shiny object because enough light is
being reflected
now on the earth the depending on
exactly what the cloud cover is and the
in the atmosphere and things like that
the albedo of the earth can change
and if the earth is reflecting more
light then
less light is getting to the surface of
the earth and there's less light
that can cause the surface to heat up
and can
produce this greenhouse effect etcetera
etcetera etcetera
so um the but but in any case the the
the sort of the the net of all this is
well yes us humans have some effect
whether that effect is big compared to
the
effects that are happening naturally
from the change of climate is not
completely clear
but uh we have an effect um well now
what what consequence will that have
well the climate of the earth will
change it would have changed even if we
weren't around
you know there are things like in um uh
um you know in massachusetts where i
live there's a
there's a big sort of peninsula called
cape cod
and um uh the um
uh you know it's something which you
know it it's gradually being eroded away
and
and in time it will all be gone and that
you can see that as a consequence of i
mean
you know the topography of the earth
changes the climate of the earth changes
it's been changing for billions of years
it's going to go on changing
and unless we put an awful lot of effort
into it we're not going to be able to
stop it changing
so what well that means that for example
there will be parts of the earth that
get warmer parts of the earth that get
colder
places where the levels of oceans go up
and so on
well and you might say well that's a
disaster
but you know it's uh there are certainly
you know there are places where if you
own a beachfront property somewhere
and the ocean is going to go up and and
uh the only way to prevent the city from
being
flooded is to put a big dike up and
that's going to hurt your view then yes
there's a problem if on the other hand
you you know own a lot of farmland
somewhere in i don't know canada or
something and it's like
that farmland can't you can't grow
certain kinds of crops because it isn't
warm enough to grow those
and gosh the climate is going to change
and then you're going to be able to grow
crops then maybe you come out ahead from
that
and there are parts of the earth where
there are places where
it's been you know that that turn into
desert that turn out of desert
and so on as the climate changes so you
know i think one of the things that's
sort of an unfortunate feature of modern
times
is probably you know these changes
happen over hundreds of years and so on
and in the past before people had locked
down we've got a city in this particular
place and so on
it's like okay the climate is changing
we're going to go herd our goats in a
different place
and this sort of gradual migration and
people move their
their yurts or whatever is somewhere
else and there's not a big deal there's
no
nobody says i have a property deed that
says i own this piece of beach
property and it's a problem for me so to
speak it just sort of gradually things
change
but now because we've advanced much
further and we've got a much more
sort of organized society these things
are a bigger problem
and so it makes makes more of a
difference so to speak and
so so then there's a question of uh you
know
are the perturbations that we humans are
making in
the in the sort of the atmosphere of the
earth what effects do they have
do they lead to you know that day when
it's really hot that day when it's
really cold that wildfire
that this that that well it's really
hard to know
you know people will try and chase that
statistically are there more hurricanes
or they're less hurricanes
although more wildfires because we
changed the forestry management
practices
although more wildfires because of
something to do with the carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere
or the temperature or whatever it's
really hard to know
and it's kind of a complicated exercise
in sort of mathematics and statistics
and so on
and i must say my my impression is it's
just really hard to know
and the so then you can ask the question
well
look one thing we could do is just let
the earth do what it was naturally going
to do and let's just reverse out
any change that we made so we increased
the carbon dioxide level which we did
you know let's reverse that out if the
earth was going to get colder or warmer
at this time let's just let it do what
it would naturally do
now we may not like what it would
naturally do and that's a separate
problem and then we have to all agree
well we're going to change what it
naturally does
and that's a very difficult thing to
agree on but you know one thing we can
think about is can we reverse out what
it's naturally doing
and there are a couple of different ways
you can do that one thing you do is say
well let's you know all this
industrialization and all these
uh all these things we're doing let's
just reverse that out let's let's go
back to a time before industrialization
you know to me that train has already
left the station so to speak in the
sense
that well the world is industrialized
and the places that
are you know where when
if you're in a place where you can spend
a lot on dealing with power
then yes you can have fancy you know
solar wind
hydrogen whatever all these different uh
forms of fuel and so on
um i think there are many places where
uh
where things are developing the economy
is not that well developed and where
it's like let's just get power the
cheapest way we can and that cheapest
way
may not turn out to be something that
doesn't sort of
belch uh carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere i would say that another
thing that i've certainly noticed
when i was a kid even in england there
was a big effort to remove pollution
in cities which was very unpleasant and
that was successfully done i don't know
how much it cost i don't know how
you know how much had to be done to
factories and putting filters on
factories and things like that but that
was a
very immediate very measurable very
obvious
effect i mean i will also say that
it is a little bit bizarre i mean in
you know there are there are you know as
a as a is it a good
thing to have clean energy oh sure it's
a good thing if you can do it
is you know when it's a trade-off
between uh
you know you've got terrible poverty or
you've got clean energy
that's a more complicated thing that's a
that's a complicated societal decision
to make
um but you know in terms of if you can
have clean energy why not have it
sure why not have it but if it comes to
you know having this effect you know how
much effort do you put in
to get such and such a number of notches
down on the effect that we've had
on on the earth well the other thing one
can think about doing
is let's just like we've had this effect
because of all this industrialization et
cetera et cetera et cetera
let's just do something that counters
that
rather than rolling back the
industrialization let's just have
something that balances all of this
carbon dioxide that we put into the
atmosphere
let's plant more trees you know there
are two trillion trees in the world
let's have more of them let's have you
know the plants
absorb carbon dioxide of course there
are issues with that you know there are
places where people want to
build cities and things rather than have
a bunch of trees there
etc etc etc but you know that's an
example but then you can go much more
technical
because there are ways to uh
absorb that carbon dioxide for example
that
are essentially hacks of various times
uh well the the one
example of uh so a couple of hacks that
i'll mention
one is uh the plankton in the oceans
the little microorganisms in the oceans
um
the uh they are
guzzlers of carbon dioxide and
if you just have more of that um uh
the plankton in certain places you can
guzzle more carbon dioxide
so how do you get more plankton well one
way you can do it is plankton
uh need iron and so if you just go and
dump iron into like the southern ocean
you can apparently so it's claimed you
can grow more plankton
and so then they'll guzzle more carbon
dioxide you reduce the amount of you
kind of you kind of
wash out the carbon dioxide from the
earth's atmosphere
there are a variety of approaches like
that there are approaches using more
industrial technology
where you have sort of anti-power plants
where you're kind of trying to
guzzle in carbon dioxide
as an approach that uses a mineral
called olivine that's very common
apparently olivine interacts with
seawater in a way that will
absorb carbon dioxide i haven't
personally verified
all of these claims about these
different kinds of chemical processes
and so on
and biochemical processes but there are
a good collection of these
processes that potentially can absorb
carbon dioxide
there are also things you can do like
you can change the albedo of the earth
you can you can put things in the
earth's in the upper atmosphere
that uh cause less sunlight to reach the
surface of the earth
and cool it down you could even put
giant
you know uh pieces of mylar up into the
up into space that reflect
uh light from the sun okay but the thing
that usually happens when you start
talking about these things
is people say but but who's going to
decide to do that you know somewhere
there's going to be this great big
you know you look up in the sky and
there's going to be this great big black
thing there
and um you know that that's blocking
sunlight you know is that is that really
what we want to do
and then what tends to happen is with
geoengineering which is this kind of
term for this
this area of kind of change the planet
by
by by using these various kinds of hacks
the thing that you have to do when you
start thinking about these kinds of
hacks is you have to say can we really
predict what's going to happen
if we start you know uh
putting things in in um um
the uh you know putting pouring
iron into the southern ocean you know
and producing plankton what's going to
happen
what's really going to happen and of
course then you have to be able to run
climate models and you have to be
trust the answers and one of the things
that's that's
sort of paradoxical is that people are
on the one hand saying look
our climate models say the earth's gonna
heat warm by this amount the sea level
is going to go up by this amount etc etc
etc
and they say so we've got to do all
these things and they say okay great
let's do these things let's do this
piece of geo engineering
let's feed that into these models after
all we think we can make models
let's put in this this geoengineering uh
sort of intervention and see what
happens
usually what you find is people say well
well let's not do that
we're not really sure these models work
that well you know gosh something else
might go wrong
so it's it's a bit of a paradoxical
situation
and of course it's deeply steeped in
politics because
the details of you know which country
pays this amount for carbon and does
this and you know what constraints are
put on different
uh kinds of activities in different
places those are questions of society
and politics and things they don't have
much to do with science
and you know as a this is not really the
subject for today but but
maybe it's more of a history question um
the
the whole dynamic of the intermeshing of
so politics and science
in the climate uh situation has been
oh i mean for me it's just a i would say
a
you know a science-oriented person it's
been kind of horrifying to watch because
in a sense the whatever the science may
be
it doesn't really matter anymore because
there's enough
kind of societal will to go in a certain
direction
that that's what people think they want
to do and that's what society wants to
do
and uh you know i don't think it's
horrible but um
and i think it will lead to some good
science and good technology and
personally i think it's
uh you know it's uh it's
it's it's probably a good thing not to
you know
uh burn those squash trees from the
covenant first period that we're using
as as oil and so on
but um uh and um where there was only
one time in the history of the earth
that that stuff got made
but you know what i remember it's
terrible how these things work because
i remember there was a time when people
said oil is going to run out we're just
going to run out of oil there's not
going to be enough oil left
and so i i uh you know oil companies
have geologists and i know some of them
and so i was asking questions about is
that really true you know
and obviously if you're an oil company
you go prospecting for
you know you go trying to figure out
where is their oil
should we buy the rights to be able to
drill in this part of the ocean or in
this
uh piece of land because gosh
we'll um uh you know we might find oil
here and so
it's a big deal to predict you know what
geological formation
will have caused there to be oil formed
in a particular place
and you know so when you ask the
question what are the places where there
might be oil
the answer is it's really hard to know
and basically people will say how much
you prepared to spend
because if you're prepared to drill
deeper do more investigation
etc you can find more oil and then
obviously with fracking
that was another hole and and shale and
all these kinds of things there were
there were
places to find oil where we didn't think
there was oil before
and it's really just a question how much
are you prepared to spend to get that
oil
it's not the case that the oh we're
going to run out of oil
um it's uh you know that that that's
that's
far away or at least nobody knows how
far away that is because nobody really
knows what the
ultimate oil deposits on the uh on the
earth are
it's really just a question of you know
how can we how can we retrieve them
um and what interesting technological
ideas are there
to get them and one of the issues is oil
and oil reservoir
in the ground is uh you know a lot it's
it's in porous rock
and there's just a whole bunch of oil
there and there's also water there
you drill down and uh you have to you
know the question is can you get the oil
out of the ground until you for example
uh pump down high pressure water
to um uh to push oil out and how does
that work in porous rock
that's an interesting subject i can talk
about porous rock at some point and
and how some of that works um in my in
my youth i happened to do a piece of
consulting
for for an oil instrumentation company
that i think
um perhaps was useful in some of the
modeling
for how that all works back in the 1980s
um well anyway so so that was uh
uh let's see whatever what did i not
mention in the
in the world of um um
uh you know in a you know in a perfect
world we'd have perfect climate models
and we'd know exactly what was going to
happen
and we'd know if you turn that
geoengineering knob
this is what will happen and then we can
have a great big debate
you know if you could turn the average
temperature of the surface of the earth
up by one degree you know some people
would say that would be fantastic and
other people say that would be horrible
and unfortunately things like a carbon
dioxide level that's a
more or less not quite but more or less
it's a global thing for the atmosphere
of the earth
and so we're kind of all in it together
so to speak and you can't just sort of
say well
you know in my country we're going to do
this i don't really care what anybody
else
does because it's kind of a role on this
planet together so to speak
um and so it's it becomes a very
complicated sort of
uh societal political set of decisions
what do you actually want to have happen
and one realizes even at the level of
much more local things which we still
don't know how to do but
if we knew how to do cloud seeding and
we could make it rain or not rain
on a particular day reliably you'd have
a whole discussion within a city for
example
do we want it to rain today or not you
know how do we decide whether it should
rain on monday
you know do we take a vote how do we you
know what happens to the minority
does the minority get to choose for some
number of days in the year
how would that possibly work in a sense
we're better off just leaving it
to nature where nature will do what
nature does
um but then it's a little bit of a
difficult sort of logical question
you know if we are putting our finger on
the scale
so to speak to change a little bit
what's happening but we don't really
know what's going to happen
you know nature is going to do something
which we don't know if we change nature
it's going to be something we don't know
what do we do about that it's a
difficult thing to answer
and um but as i say it's one where a lot
of the kind of decision making
is is something that's gone into the
political realm rather the scientific
realm
and uh you know i i think personally
that uh the technology of clean energy
and so on is a fine thing
and you know whatever
okay let's see
um
questions about carbon capture and
whether this is
um
well
um
yeah it's a good question whether if you
capture the carbon
you know i'm i'm reminded i found
recently
a strange essay that i wrote when i was
like 11 years old which is 1971.
so when the world was a different kind
of place
but where one of the problems was the
sort of buildup of trash in the world
and
um so in my 11 year old essay my
conclusion was the ultimate thing to do
with trash in the world
is put it on a spacecraft and throw it
into the sun
um so i don't know what uh
uh you know i think there are
the question of of how sort of carbon is
ingested inside the earth
and and what happens in in different
kinds of rocks and carbon and rocks
versus carbon in the atmosphere i don't
know how that all works
i will say that the total amount of
carbon in the atmosphere is pretty tiny
compared to the amount of carbon in
rocks because rocks are solid and they
have a much higher density of atoms
and so it's it's inevitable this is
going to be a lot more carbon
there than there is ever in the in the
in the gaseous atmosphere
um okay so
motu as was mentioning is is climate
change necessarily bad
as in what equilibrium may be reach
after the instability is stabilized and
what would that equilibrium
would that equilibrium necessarily be
worse than the one we have you know
the other question is is anything
destabilizing that's not clear either
i mean in other words if it is the case
that we have made
changes that have a significant effect
on climate which probably we have who
knows
um you know are they destabilizing
changes
or are they changes that just make some
parameter
move at a different rate and there's
nothing you know there's not it's not
going to increase the volatility
of climate change or anything it's just
going to mean that
you know the the time when the next ice
stage happens
you know let's imagine the next ice age
is 50 000 years away
maybe we just moved it to 70 000 years
away
you know i don't know is that good is
that bad who's to know um
it's i don't think there's any real
evidence
that a sort of unpredictability
of the climate has increased i think
that there may be
a perception that it has because
weather forecasting is hard but we
expect everything to be forecastable
but it isn't and there are sort of
fundamental
sort of scientific reasons why these
things are hard to predict that's a
different topic
um about particularly the phenomenon of
computational irreducibility
um in the case of weather forecasting a
famous thing is sort of
the chaos theory effect in fact back in
1963 a chap called ed laurence
who i who i used to know um
meteorologist at mit
um figured out that in a kind of very
simplified mathematical model of the
weather
if you just changed one number by just a
tiny tiny bit
you change one number in its tenth
decimal digit then eventually that
change in the number in the tenth
decimal digit
could affect the overall behavior of the
system
so that sort of turned into this idea
that you know if a butterfly flaps its
wings
um at a particular moment that could
lead to a hurricane
which wouldn't have happened if the
butterfly hadn't flapped its wings
well the truth of that situation is
those times when the butterfly flap
really makes a difference are a very
very very tiny set of times
most of the time the effect of the
butterfly just dies out
most of the times like you flap your
hands in the air most of the time
the the air currents that you produce
will be damped out by viscosity
essentially friction in the air
and no no consequence but just sometimes
the time when you flap your hands
will cause that little packet of air
that was
you know where something was just on the
edge of some
some uh uh air being pulled up from an
ocean somewhere that should produce a
hurricane
it was just on the edge of would it make
a hurricane would it not
at this bifurcation point where it's
going to kind of go one way or the other
it's like you have a beam
and you're pushing on the two ends and
it's going to buckle and it's either
going to buckle up or it's going to
buckle down
it's kind of a very detailed question
whether it goes up or whether it goes
down
and so there can be these situations
where you're at these sort of
bifurcation points
where it can be sensitively dependent on
these
initial conditions and and in the case
of of the weather
there are these places where that will
happen in general
well there's a it's a little bit more
complicated and when you do weather
forecasting
and you make changes in the initial
parameters there is
a a progressive deviation of the final
result from the initial result
but there are questions about about how
fast that happens and so on
the questions about what can make a
change what doesn't make a change
and so on so the real reason for
difficulty i think in particularly
long-term
uh climate forecasting is more is the
story of computational irreducibility
it's a story of there are computations
where the only way to work out the
outcome of the computations
is to just do the computation and and
that's
um but unfortunately you both have to do
the computation
and you have to get all the details
right in order to
correctly predict that climate kind of
thing so
it's um it's a really challenging thing
and uh uh i think
it's you know i i
i haven't personally looked at i have
looked at some weather forecasting codes
i have not personally looked at
the climate computation codes um the
programs i
i think they are fairly uh
they've it's very difficult to know what
the right answer is it's very difficult
to know whether you've got all the right
effects in there or not
i mean i'll give you uh two other
examples perhaps about complicated codes
where where
all kinds of strange things happened
historically
when people try to work out the
explosion of stars and supernovas
that's a complicated problem of nuclear
physics and people have these big codes
to try and work it out
those codes happen to be very closely
related to the codes that were used to
work out nuclear weapons
uh explosions because those are also a
story of nuclear physics and nuclear
reactions
well there was a long period of time
when people said supernovas just can't
happen
well it turned out there was a detailed
mistake of particular
neutrino opacity data cards i think that
have been mistyped
that caused the calculation to just get
the wrong answer
and that's a that's a feature of these
complicated codes that depend on many
things
depend on the details of how many cloud
layers and how many mountains you put in
and
whether you account for some effect of
ice crystal formation or not and
all this kind of thing you know what
matters what doesn't really hard to know
and it's really hard to debug these
codes because it's not like you say well
let's just
rerun it and let's just see whether it
reproduces correctly what happens on the
earth in this case in that case
it's it's very hard to do that kind of
testing because we don't have we only
have one earth to
to look at and we only have one chain of
history with all of its details to look
at
another case where people were concerned
with these codes was in nuclear reactor
safety
where again it was really hard to know
whether
whether the calculations would actually
come out correctly and
and sort of the uh uh it's a it's always
a challenging thing
all right i think that's about um
all i can say uh
um
about um uh
um
yeah various people are commenting here
on uh do we really understand the
plankton well enough
or will they make something else worse
so who knows i mean that's the problem
you kind of have to know everything i
mean you know we've kind of seen the
effect of it's
it's hard to know what's going to happen
in the pandemic and the epidemiology of
this pandemic
but people are also saying we can
calculate we'll figure out
you know using um simple models of of
epidemiology
will figure out what's going to happen
it turns out it was more complicated now
it was really hard to figure out
what happens and whether we've even
accounted for all the correct effects is
very unclear
whether we've accounted for the correct
you know effects of
of human immunology of kind of the uh
people with long-term carrying of low
levels of virus
all this kind of thing we don't know uh
you know the one thing that has happened
in this pandemic is amazing focus on
virology
the study of viruses and um you know
no doubt more will be learned more has
been learnt
about that in just these few you know
this year and the next few years
probably
that has been learnt throughout the
whole history of the subject before that
because endlessly more testing more
experiments more theoretical analysis
has been done but it's very notable that
we've been very unable to predict in
that
and i knew this back from the beginning
of this pandemic um
actually um my son christopher did a
particularly big study
of this looking at kind of the the the
effects of different kinds of
ways that people could be connected to
each other you know the very standard
model of epidemiology
so-called sir models make the assumption
that all humans mix so you know you're
meeting strangers all the time
everybody if there's a certain fraction
of people who are infected they're going
to infect some other people
and everybody's just randomly mixed but
the truth of it is
in most parts of of society and so on
people aren't meeting strangers all the
time every day some places they are
but in many many people are not many
people have some kind of
definite network of people that they
interact with and as soon as you start
dealing with those definite networks you
have completely different results
from what you get with these sort of
random mixing models and people try and
partition the random mixing models and
say let's have a ten compartment random
mixing model
where people of this age range won't mix
with people of this age range
whatever else but in the end it's very
hard to know and the question is
are the results you get robust
independent of what you assume about how
that mixing works
and the answer is no they're not only a
very few results are robust
and come out the same independent of how
that mixing works
many results come out completely
differently like an example of a result
that seemed to be pretty much
independent of that is
it's worse for for contagion to have
a small number of large gatherings than
a large number of small gatherings of
people
that um are almost independent of how
the network of connectivity of people
works
that's a bad that that works that way
but lots of other things
you can't tell and that's a this is a
great example
of sort of computational irreducibility
at work and also the fact that you have
to know
what effects do you really need to
account for on the model and what don't
you to to make a correct prediction and
it's turned out to be really difficult
in this case
uh okay is commenting
think how lucky human beings are we had
one asteroid hit the earth to make the
moon
because of seasons plants to grow make
oil and coal
then an asteroid kills the dinosaurs
that might have eaten us
um then uh
we get um yes then we get enough um
uh free reign to start up nuclear
fission nuclear fusion and so on becomes
self-sustaining etc
what luck we've had you know i have to
say one of the things i've noticed
from studying biology and natural
selection and so on
is that one thing that biology is always
doing
is being opportunistic you know when
a mollusk randomly picks some shell of a
certain
shape then it discovers that given the
shell of that shape
i can do this cool thing and that other
cool thing
um i doubt that you know so in other
words
there is a lot of luck to be found so to
speak
that is if it turned out we didn't have
a moon
for the earth and we had a different
different characteristics for our
seasons and whatever else
um then you know
i think sort of if they've been life
formed on earth it would have found a
way it will be different from what we
have now
let's say the ozone layer didn't exist
on the earth well
does that mean there couldn't be any
life because it would all get burnt to a
crisp no absolutely not
there are forms of life that are robust
against ultraviolet radiation
and uh you know we would have been
different from the way we are
we are the way we are uh you know
because we fit into the kind of
niches that exist on the earth as it is
but
i i think it's fair to say that that
there's tremendous
kind of opportunity for life to be a
different way
so to speak even within the the detailed
biochemistry that we have
um i think there was one other comment
here about
hydrogen fusion um
yeah well you know
people thought after the first nuclear
weapons and so on the first hydrogen
bombs
that it would be easy to make energy the
same way the sun does
by nuclear fusion of hydrogen for
example it turned out to be really hard
to contain you have to get these
these plasmas up to you know 10 million
degrees centigrade and things
it's really hard to to keep something
bottled up
at that temperature and so on and it's
been people have been trying for
70 years now to do that for various
reasons
there is a recent uh great enthusiasm
for being able to control nuclear fusion
um and there are a whole bunch of
companies
that have started up with various
different designs for how to use
magnetic
bottles and things to to uh uh
to kind of um to to uh
to to kind of box in this uh very high
temperature plasma
um and maybe in the next some number of
years
uh controlled nuclear fission will be
achieved uh
uh one can it's easy to achieve in very
small amounts
um but it's not possible to achieve it
at the level where
you're getting out more energy than
you're putting in
um let's see
i think i've been going a while here so
um
maybe a few more
questions um there's a question here do
we think there are
life forms out there where the spectrum
of visible light is totally different
from ours
um you know uh what you count as a life
form is a complicated issue
if you say things that have chemistry
similar to ours which may be a very
small
chance but let's say that they do then
absolutely the
the um the things the the range of
frequencies of light that we are
sensitive to
is just the ones that happen to make it
to the surface of the earth pretty much
and uh you know that's what the
photoreceptors in our eyes you know it
all started with the trilobites they
were the first critters
that had eyes back in the cambrian
period um and
they um uh they're photoreceptors you
know
a protein uh was developed that um or
arose
that had sensitivity to photons of light
in this range of frequencies and you
know work for the trilobites and we've
been going with it ever since
i don't actually know if the trilobites
have the same photoreceptors that we do
but i bet that they i think it's very
likely that they did it's
it's sort of very embarrassing if you
look at many of our
biological mechanisms molecular biology
of
us there are so many molecules that have
been very conserved
for the last billion years or more in
the history of life it's like we have
the same mechanism for dealing with i
don't know
you know even things like insulin and so
on that existed in these
organisms just like a gazillion uh
gazillion years ago
it's like we didn't invent a lot of new
stuff whatever it is that we humans
got to get working was a very
thin thing on top of all of these layers
of biology that that
were already existed
all right um
let's see
it's a question here from guile do you
think there's a plateau we must break
through for space exploration to be more
feasible
or is our progress as is good enough
look when i was a kid
everybody knew there were going to be
mars colonies by the 1990s
obviously there weren't something went
wrong what mainly went wrong
was not that it was impossible but that
people
said what's the point why are we going
to spend billions of dollars
sending spacecraft to wherever you know
we've got plenty of problems here on
earth let's go work on those
and not sort of burn our money up in
rocket fuel so to speak
and you know there are applications of
space communication satellites
uh reconnaissance things things like
that
that have gradually uh the gps system
things like that
that have gradually become more
significant but they don't really
justify going to the moon yet
they don't really justify going to mars
and
we don't really quite yet know what the
big payoff for
you know having having a luna colony for
example will be i don't know what it
will be
it's an interesting question it's sort
of an interesting thing to think about
um you know just like when computers
were first invented uh what will be the
big payoff from
from that idea it wasn't sort of the
solving of mathematical problems
although
we tried to do our part for that that
was sort of an original idea for things
about computers
it was all kinds of other things about
storing information communicating
et cetera et cetera et cetera that
turned out to be the biggest uh obvious
wins for computers
one of the more bizarre you know what's
going to happen type things this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that i mentioned
that i kind of uh figured out in the in
the early 1980s
this way of of uh understanding that
there are computations where you kind of
need to go through all the steps in the
computation
to get to the results you're kind of
burning computational effort to get to
the results
and sort of a question of what's that
going to be useful for
and uh in a in a just a very bizarre
turn of fate
um that's i think what turned into the
kind of proof-of-work idea for
cryptocurrencies for things like bitcoin
that you kind of show that you have a
valuable thing
by burning computer time to do that
and you have to burn the computer time
because of computational irreducibility
and so i certainly would never have
expected when i was inventing that sort
of abstract idea of computational
irreducibility
that it would turn into this thing where
you're proving you did computation and
you're
you're burning electricity to do it for
the sake of of uh
of producing cryptocurrencies just never
would have occurred to me
so similarly when we talk about you know
putting a colony on the moon
it's just not obvious what that's going
to be good for i mean yes we can put
you know we maybe can make a great radio
telescope on the far side of the moon
and
maybe when we make the great radio
telescope we'll discover that we
can be part of a giant galactic
conversation with all those aliens and
so on
and that will tell us all kinds of new
discoveries or maybe it will turn out
that um the moon uh uh
you know i i don't know what the what
the applications of of having
something you know having colony on the
moon will be maybe maybe there'll be a
a sort of a giant trend of running giant
ads on the surface of the moon and uh
you know i i what good that would be i'm
not sure i think it'd probably
be a kind of a a weird thing
but um i think uh uh
the question of sort of is there a
technological plateau
that needs to be um uh
got passed and i think one of them is
reusable rockets and that seems to be
being
uh you know being that that problem is
being licked
right now that that problem is being
solved i mean that that's been a
difficult problem to solve
but that one looks like it's it's
happening i mean another one is
reliability
you know it traditionally has been the
case that like one in 50 rockets blows
up
i don't know if that's still true uh
clearly
having more sensors and more ability to
figure out what's happening earlier
maybe more ability to simulate things
can change that those numbers
um you know that's obviously an issue um
and
and no doubt there are ways of building
you know an increasing
number of sort of fail-safe uh you know
safety layers that can help that but you
know is there is there some sort of
magic idea
that will allow the cost of sending
things into space to go down
obviously reusability is a big feature
of that um but there are other things
like their ideas like um uh you know
rail guns where you'll use
some uh uh electrical mechanism to kind
of shoot things at very high speed and
maybe shoot them into orbit
there's also these things where there's
a there's a scheme where you're spinning
things around very very quickly
um and suddenly you you kind of let go
and you open this door
and the in the system and you let go and
this thing will spin off and
you know it's been spinning around will
be the center if you go force so to
speak will make the thing just
zoom off into at a high enough speed to
go into orbit
uh some of those kinds of schemes have
issues because they're very high
accelerations
and certainly humans aren't going to
survive through all of that
although probably electronics for
example can survive through that
um so there are things like that that
will reduce the cost of um
its uh
you know reduce the cost of um uh of
putting things in space
and there's a question what are we going
to get for putting things in space you
know if it becomes
if there's a point at which it's cheap
enough to put things in space
will there be dramatic new uses for
space that haven't even become
conceivable yet i mean this certainly
happened with computers
back when computers even when i started
using computers in the early 1970s
there were tons of things that that you
would never have considered using a
computer for because computers were way
too expensive
to do any of those kinds of things with
them and yet by the time computers get
cheap enough
there is these dramatic uses that make
high value for computers
um that happen because they suddenly got
cheap enough and and the same thing
could happen
um it uh um
um uh could happen with things like
um exploring the moon um there's a
comment
uh here um
there's a comment here from neuro about
sustainable energy uh going back to our
our discussion about climate change uh
mentioning they're skeptical that
renewables like solar and wind can meet
growing demand
um you know can can nuclear approaches
work better
um you know i don't know i haven't
really studied the the solar and wind
case i mean i i i think uh
you know there are the conversion of
light
into electricity by photovoltaic cells
the big issue there is how efficient can
that be
and then there are more minor issues
like
uh how much does it cost to actually put
out that number of photovoltaics or in
parts of the world where you're in a
giant desert where there's tons of
sunlight
um you know what happens when um uh you
know you get
a whole layer of sand and you have to
have these little critters that come and
clean the sand off your of your solar
panels
and then of course there's the question
you know if we put enough solar panels
that are absorbing enough
light from the sun uh how does that
affect
kind of global climate even by itself
it's like building
you know i don't think that the the area
of solar panels is large enough
that it's going to have a big effect but
it's not clear because it's like cities
have an effect because they're much
darker than the surrounding area
and solar panels are effectively like
that too but
people have been looking for a while for
kind of a magic new substance
that can be a more efficient converter
of the energy of
light into electricity none has been
found yet
but that's something that could be found
any day somebody could find some strange
chemical compound that would be just a
spectacular photovoltaic
with much higher efficiency and very
cheap to produce
and that would change the whole equation
for solar power
when it comes to wind you know these big
wind turbines they're really expensive
and it's a complicated issue what
the fact that you know having a bunch of
wind turbines in different places
probably i doesn't you know locally it
has an effect on the wind it probably
doesn't have a global effect it's
probably
probably far far away from having a
global effect um
what is the sort of the price curve of
how much does it cost to build the wind
turbine
versus how much are you getting for what
it costs part of that is a societal
decision
you know if you say we just don't want
to be burning coal anymore
so let's spend the money on a giant on
lots of wind farms well that's a
decision one can make
um it may be an expensive decision and
that's a complicated question of
economics and
and that's not um let's not segue into
talking about economics
uh here today so alistair observes about
uh talking about uh uh
going to visit you know put colonies on
the moon and so on
um makes the perhaps uh tongue-in-cheek
comment
we could study moon rocks in greater
detail and then after that we can do it
again
um yeah well the geology of the moon is
kind of interesting because
unlike the earth where which has an
atmosphere
and where there's been erosion and water
you know it's been rain and that washes
rocks away and
there are oceans and that kind of carves
things out and there's been a
pr and there's soil and there's all
kinds of things happening there's this
gradual erosion of rocks on the surface
of the earth
on the moon what was there four billion
years ago is probably still there today
um and the moon doesn't even have a
liquid core there are no volcanoes
there it's um it's just the way it was
when it first started out whatever 4.6
billion years ago or something
and um it's it's i think the case that
you know a footprint
there that you know in the in the little
lunar dust
it's still going to be there a billion
years from now if some tourist hasn't
erased
it nothing much happens on the moon it's
a very
pristine environment in which to explore
what the early solar system was like
uh why do we care well it's interesting
uh i had a friend
well yeah who who um had a company that
uh was i guess they're still going to
send a moon
moon probe although it's been multiple
times delayed
but they had the idea of bringing back
moon rocks
and then the big idea was
gosh you know diamonds are valuable and
people think diamonds are cool
what about moon rocks all the better to
have you know a moon rock ring
than a diamond ring it's something more
exotic more rare and so on i
i kept on trying to persuade this this
person i i know
um you know get some crystallographers
involved figure out how you can
uh you know take find the right kind of
moon rock
and cut it the right way because you
know with diamond diamond you know when
people have diamonds that they put in
rings and so on
the um they wear whatever they um
uh part of the the trick of diamonds is
that they their faces they're cut in a
particular shape
so that the when light goes into the
diamond the the refractive index of
diamond this butchers
tells you the speed that light goes out
inside the diamond diamond has a
refractive index of 2.7 so
light goes 2.7 times slower in diamond
than does in
in the air and that causes there to be a
lot of
total internal reflection inside the
diamond
so the light kind of goes into the
diamond it bounces around a bunch of
times before it comes out
but the details of how it comes in how
it goes out depend on all the angles
of all the cuts in the in the crystal
and so
depending on the detailed crystalline
structure of diamond you make these cuts
at different angles and so on and you
have to figure out the same kind of
thing for moon rock or if there even is
a moon rock
that can uh produce the same kind of
interesting visual effects that diamonds
can produce
so that's sort of a feature of studying
studying moon rock i i think
that um uh you know we don't really know
quite
what the um the details
of um uh you know what might be mineable
on the moon that will be useful i mean
it looks like
different on the earth it's kind of a
weird thing
where um the uh
you know you say where are the gold
deposits on the earth well there are
particular countries that have lots of
gold deposits where the uranium deposits
where are the tantalum deposits where
the niobium deposits
you know the one thing that's a general
rule is if it's a big country
there's probably deposits of stuff
somewhere in it
and you know that's been significant in
in
in sort of the uh in mining around the
world
um you know the big countries will have
some
gold deposit some tantalum deposit with
some probability somewhere
but in the formation of the earth you
know for whatever reason
the tantalum all wound up in different
places i think there's
what is it rwanda china various other
places have tantalum who knows why
um but just as there's segregation in
these different materials on the surface
of the earth
so also in the solar system there's
segregation of these things so different
asteroids
for example one will have a large amount
of one particular element
another will have a large amount of
another particular element on the moon i
don't think we know
a good kind of geological survey of the
whole moon
of what exists there i mean maybe
there's lots of gold somewhere on the
moon
uh you know for what that's worth um you
know maybe they'll be discovered right
around the time when the actual value of
gold
is no longer important and it's all
cryptocurrencies all the way down i
don't know
um but uh uh so you know
it's a it's a very interesting question
what you know if we had a moon colony
what would it be good for
um and as i say i i i think there's a
good chance
that it would turn out well we can ask
the same thing about the antarctic for
example
when there are you know when there's
scientific research stations in the
antarctic what have they been good for
turns out there are some cool things you
can do there quite literally in terms of
temperature but but
uh also things like there are particle
detectors that have been built at the
south pole
um there are observations about the
atmosphere that can be made in
antarctica
there are things like that it's not
dramatic it's not like
you know a city of a hundred thousand
has grown up in antarctica because
there's so many important things to do
there
but there's some things and whether it
will turn out that on the moon
there's uh sort of antarctic level
things to do or whether there's more or
whether there's less i'm not sure
interesting question interesting thing
to to kind of think about
all right well there were lots of other
interesting questions here about very
different topics
but i should
wrap up for now here thanks for joining
and see you another time